WORLD LIKE YOU DID TWO YEARS
AGO.
YOU HAVE TO GO VOTE.
JOINING WITH US REACTION FORMER
CLINTON POLLSTER, MARK PENN.
THE AUTHOR OF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BEST SELLER "JESUS IS
RISEN" DAVID LIMBAUGH, DAVID HAS
DONE LEGAL WORK FOR ME IN THE
PAST.
YOU HAVE ALSO, I'VE NEVER BEEN A
GREAT CHRISTIAN THAT YOU ARE,
YOUR BOOKS HAVE MADE ME A BETTER
PERSON.
LET ME PUT IT THAT WAY.
VERY INFORMATIVE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THEIR AGENDA,
WE SEE THAT PEOPLE ARE OPENLY
LYING.
I DON'T SEE AN AGENDA FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AT ALL.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO TO
MAKE THE COUNTRY BETTER TO HELP
THE PEOPLE OF THE COUNTRY?
>> THEY UTTERLY HAVE NO AGENDA.
SO THEY PIT AMERICANS AGAINST
OTHER AMERICANS.
BLACK AGAINST WHITE, WOMEN
AGAINST MEN, RICH AGAINST POOR.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO OUTRAGED
ABOUT KANYE, HE IS FINALLY
COMING OUT AND STRAYING FROM THE
DEMOCRAT PLANTATION.
ONLY DEMOCRATS -- ONLY BLACKS
WHO SUPPORT THE LIBERAL CAUSE
CAN READ.
WE ARE TO ASSUME, THINK ABOUT
WHAT THESE PEOPLE ON MSNBC WERE
SAYING, KANYE CAN'T READ BECAUSE
HE SUPPORTS CONSERVATIVES.
THAT MEANS, BLACKS WHO SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT WILL HELP THEM,
DON'T READ.
IT'S JUST AMAZING.
THEY HAVE NO SUBSTANTIVE
POLICIES THAT WORK.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU WORKED FOR
THE CLINTONS BUT YOU'RE A
POLLSTER.
BOTTOM LINE AS AN AMERICAN, I
WANT EVERY AMERICAN TO HAVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
NICE HOUSE, SAFE NEIGHBORHOOD,
DECENT CAR, TAKE THEIR KIDS TO
DISNEY, GO OUT TO EAT ONCE EVERY
WEEK OR EVERY OTHER WEEK, NOT
HAVE TO WORRY, SAVE A LITTLE FOR
RETIREMENT.
THAT IS ACHIEVABLE.
BUT UNDER BARACK OBAMA, WE
WEREN'T WAY BACKWARDS.
DONALD TRUMP'S POLICIES ARE
WORKING.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR REPUBLICANS TO
NOW BRING IN TO FOLD DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUPS THAT HAVEN'T VOTED
REPUBLICANS?
>> AS POLLSTER, DONALD TRUMP
SITS AT ABOUT 45% APPROVAL.
THAT'S BELOW THE 50% THAT A
PRESIDENT REALLY NEEDS DESPITE
THE GOOD ECONOMY.
SO THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
ISSUES, A LOT OF TERMS, A LOT OF
POSITIONS --
>> Sean: BUT HE'S ONLY A BIT
HIGHER THAN BARACK OBAMA AT THE
SAME TIME OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> THAT'S TRUE, BUT HE
STABILIZED HIS POLLING.
HASN'T GOTTEN ABOVE 50.
DEMOCRATS BELIEVE IN THE
AMERICAN DREAM TOO.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE THEY OFFERING
THIS ELECTION, WHAT ARE THEY
RUNNING ON EXCEPT HATE TRUMP,
OPEN BORDERS, KEEP OBAMA CARE
AND TAKE THE CRUMBS BACK.
>> A LOT OF DEMOCRATS RUNNING ON
HEALTHCARE, A BELIEF THAT THE
REPUBLICANS --
>> Sean: OBAMACARE HEALTHCARE.
>> OBAMACARE HAS HAD A
RESURGENCE, FROM WHERE IT WAS.
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE SAYING REALLY
BAD THINGS, AND LOOK I DON'T
LIKE WHAT HILLARY SAID OR HOLDER
SAID BECAUSE I THINK THAT
MICHELLE OBAMA IS RIGHT,
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO STAY HIGH.
WHEN THEY DON'T STAY HIGH THEY
GIVE --
>> Sean: HER OWN HIS BAND SAID
GET INTO PEOPLE'S FACES, HE SAID
I'M GOING TO SEND MR. BURGESS TO
FOX NEWS AND TAKE ON SEAN
HANNITY AND TEAR HIM UP.
>> WHEN HE WAS PRESIDENT, HE WAS
MOVED OVER TO THE CENTER,
REACHED OUT TO THE OTHER SIDE,
FIND THE PLACE, I THINK
DEMOCRATS WOULD DO BET IF THEY
DID THAT TODAY.
>> Sean: 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS, 8
MILLION IN POVERTY.
HE NEVER REACH 3% GDP.
RECORD GROWTH FOR EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC, DAVID LIMBAUGH.
>> OBAMA DID NOT REACH OUT.
HE SAID GET IN THE BACK SEAT OF
THE CAR, WE DON'T WANT YOU TO
TALK.
HE WAS THE MOST DIVISIVE.
THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT, WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO MARK, I DO
RESPECT A LOT, I DON'T THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STANDS FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM, THEY STAND FOR
THE FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE, FOR
SOCIALISM.
WHICH HISTORICALLY HAS
IMPOVERISHED AND ENSLAVED PEOPLE
AND LED TO TOTALITARIANISM.
AND THE LEFT IS TOTALITARIAN.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T WALK.
OBAMA, OBAMACARE, MILLIONS LOST
THEIR PLANS.